bonjour à toutes et à tous ça fait
plaisir de vous retrouver quand on me
dit matière noire moi je pense à ça
alors que certaines personnes peuvent
avoir des réflexions un petit peu plus
élaboré vous vous êtes jamais demandé
comment les galaxies ses immenses nuages
d'étoilés de gaz liés par leur gravité
évolué au cours de l'histoire du cosmos
pour comprendre ces objets on a
plusieurs solutions
on peut soit regarder les mêmes galaxie
pendant plusieurs milliards d'années
ou bien on peut recréer toute l'histoire
de l'univers dans une immense
simulations informatiques
étonnamment la deuxième solution est de
très très loin la plus simple on peut
pas mettre une galaxie sur une balance
modifier la température d'une étoile
pour voir ce qui se passe ou encore
mettre un capteur tout près d'un trou
noir pour étudier l'évolution des
galaxies les chercheurs et chercheuses
ont donc recours à ce qu'on appelle des
simulations cosmologique qui ont pour
but de rejouer l'évolution de l'univers
selon les prédictions nos meilleurs
théorie bon évidemment on n'est pas dans
matrix il s'agit pas de reproduire
l'univers à toutes les échelles on n'a
juste pas la puissance de calcul pour
pour le moment ces simulations se
concentre donc seulement sur
l'information des plus grandes
structures du cosmos les règles du jeu
ici ce sont les lois de la physique qui
gouvernent comment la gravité fonctionne
comment les gaz se comporte dans quelles
conditions les étoiles se forment et
évoluent la composition initiale de
l'univers etc etc
ces simulations commence quelques
centaines de milliers d'années après le
big bang
à une époque où l'univers n'est qu'un
brouillard indistinct d'hydrogène et
d'hélium dans cet immense purée de pois
on peut néanmoins discerner quelques
grumeaux
certaines régions sont très légèrement
plus dense que d'autres et grâce à la
force de gravité plus et grumeaux son
massif plus il attire de la matière
autour d'eux
au bout du compte la matière va finir
par s'arranger en immense filaments qui
vont constituer ce qu'on appelle la
toile cosmique et sur laquelle vont se
tisser au fil des milliards d'années les
galaxies et les amas de galaxies pour
remplir votre univers virtuel primordial
vous aurez besoin de trois ingrédients
principaux
une cuillère à café de gaz
intergalactique qui vous servira à
produire vos étoiles et vous galaxie une
grosse louche de votre ingrédients
secrets
la matière noire c'est un peu le lion il
faut absolument mettre sinon ça marche
pas le truc avec la matière noire c'est
qu'elle n'aim ait pas de lumière d'où le
nom moyens du coup comme elle est
invisible à nos télescopes
on sait pas encore ce que c'est pour
contre on sait que cette matière noire
existe parce qu'elle a des effets bien
réel elle agit notamment par le biais de
sa gravité sur le mouvement des galaxies
et des amas de galaxies qu'on observe
d'ailleurs la matière noire est au moins
cinq fois plus abondante que la matière
normale celle qui émet de la lumière et
qui constituent les étoiles les galaxies
et surtout jean claude van damme
mais revenons à notre recette il ne
reste plus qu à saupoudrer votre
simulation d'une pincée des toiles
massive qui explosent à la fin de leur
vie en éjectant des éléments chimiques
lourds dans le milieu intergalactique
c'est avec ça qu'on fait des planètes
des astéroïdes de la vie et surtout jean
claude van damme
laisser mijoter tout ça ensemble pendant
quelques milliards d'années virtuelle
dans de puissants supercalculateurs et
voilà il n'ya plus qu'à admirer veaux
galaxy et vos amas de galaxies se former
et à les comparer aux vrais les
scientifiques du cral le centre de
recherche astrophysique de lyon ont
récemment lancé une énorme simulation
cosmologique pour tenter de comprendre
comment le rayonnement et les explosions
des étoiles massives limite la
croissance des galaxies
en attendant la fin du calcul on se fait
une toile cosmique
dans sa t'abonner et à jeter un oeil aux
enzo fender
follow me aka bio